hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry we're
gonna check out the honest trailer today
for eight my Oh
oh boy mmm my favorite solo artist slash
R a smarter he is awesome I love love
Slim Shady
but I bet he's on slim down there but I
bet it's a little shady still what he
likes to do you know and me yeah sugar
and I was aggressive in bed yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] imma [ __ ] you oh yeah you don't
get into that nasally recently yeah the
[ __ ] faces off I love a mile I really
do love this
got me in a rap from the guy who always
raps about his crazy mom a little girl
named hailey and the city of Detroit
comes a film about a rapper with a crazy
mom and a little girl named Julie said
in the city of Detroit but he's got
brown hair set up on hair so it's
totally not even in a mile I seen pop
stars make terrible vanity projects like
glitter crossroads and Kulas eyes drop
that zero and cute huh yeah and uh watch
Eminem of all people do a respectful
understated job in the story of a man
struggling against a world that judges
him based on the color of his skin look
at me once thank you it won't matter
what color it's kinda like Rosa Parks in
Reverse um pretty sure they might have
an idea journey to Detroit a Depression
hit city where no one is safe from
spontaneous freestyle rapping they only
give us 30 minutes to eat lunch and
cheer then there B is called the
Caribbean you're dreaming if you think
them corny ass perhaps a work
stuck in a dead-end job at the Uptown
button-pressing factory then we'll have
one shot to rap battle his way out okay
maybe two three if you count this rap
battle right here wait does this one
qualifies a shot I guess technically is
at least fifty two shots a year since
I'm pretty sure they actually hold that
rap battle like every weekend you've
already seen Marshall Mathers take on
the role of Eminem you chill game yo get
this the routing mmm mmm hey ray hello
Marshall and gay in the damn aisle
almost sexual now he'll take on the role
of his own lifetime as Jamie bunny
rabbit Smith jr. and Emma Nimish white
rapper who's so poor he can only afford
one sheet of paper watch is a good point
to decide which emotion he'll have in
the next scene none of them
No so the doctor said to hit an artery I
just pour all of them I can't let him
just talk to you like this why did you
get it do yo your friends don't even
know me I told you how to tie me up man
no idea what anybody puts up with you
horn with only a Walkman and the world's
largest pair of sweat pants right a law
as this underdog struggles to to beat
the Cobra Kai of rap get the girl and
form a reliable carpool wait on this
slow air ride so she's a rock now left
in a car let me borrow your car it's
fine all right thank you mom from car my
mom's got the car thank you you're right
can you give me rock since some of us
right did I get a ride welcome oh boy I
give you ride to work in the morning
follow along on Eminem's racks to a
slightly more confident rack story
that'll have you bobbing your head to
the incredible rap lyrics and forgetting
all the not so incredible ones you've
worked at this plant so long you're a
plant as Eminem proves me wrong no one
is better at making a crowd say Oh
oh yeah that's right let's anthony
mackie forgot
so throw on your BT put up your hood and
sing along to the oscar-winning end
credits song about Eminem's life that's
been at the top of your workout mix
since 2002 even though the only words
you know are Mossberg a Mossberg a
Mossberg a Mossberg a starring Ravi
Balboa judge dreads get it cuz he's a
judge and he has dreadlocks never mind
trailer parks odd wife's lying spaghetti
monster huh Haley Angry Bird yo dawg i
heard you like cameos middle fingers
and clap clap hugs - from like Law &
Order schism
mm the movie oh man
can't wait for the Drake movie about
making it out of that wheelchair
Degrassi write to me
look what you know that no that's gonna
be tight be sure it's more honest
trailers hey screen junkies do you like
watching movie fans yell about movies
then tune in this Sunday Sunday Sunday
to serve in times movie pardon leather
show that I should idle by go on live on
YouTube with as if I can just ever go on
there just walk up just buy a screenshot
easily find out which movie phonetic
will reign supreme um okay yeah honest
trailers is doing their job but um first
I was like well yeah I mean everyone
knows it's supposed to be inspired by
Eminem's life but never kind of making
fun of it as if like hey look at the
correlations but I feel like this one
was a little more of a stretch I feel
like they have a harder time with really
pretty much yeah the first like two
minutes I was like just point out like
yeah that does happen is a good movie
that's a funny fits it's an awesome on a
nap clap hug shakes like that was pretty
funny though the clap clap hug snaps are
really a really there the whole city of
Detroit has one one cool handshake and a
lot of rides to give yeah I got [ __ ] was
funny what eight mile to me is like a
super inspiring film yeah you know like
you they made a lion here where it was
like from rags to riches from slightly
better or something like the rags to
slightly better right yeah yeah but to
me that's why I love that ending of a
mile because it's about him who we had
to become to get on the journey of
success yeah you know you know he's
headed upward yeah you know from that
point on that he's that's where Eminem
stories gonna take off you know but it's
not about the biopic of him taking off
like that it's about what he had to go
through and who he had to become in
order to get on that train it's just the
origin story of the Eminem Cinematic
Universe yeah that'd be really cool I
forgot how many people were in there
Michael Shannon Kim Basinger oh yeah
Anthony Matheny make me high fiber and
exhibits in that one scene yeah that big
dude who's on like CSI Miami or whatever
now in place cheddar Bob damn I don't
know that guy's name but I've seen him
in about yeah
step two but no I love a mile and no
there was some pretty funny [ __ ] in this
video anyway guys thanks for tuning in
to the channel if you're new to it you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can you can check out reasons to Jerry
and dank ass Stubbs on this channel and
either follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine and periscope or if we get
enough followers we can get even more
product placement for things such as
pills bills are great they come in
vitamin form they can come a medication
form they can also come in a thing
called Molly's mollies are awesome so
you're gonna make a viagra joke actually
oh wait take two they also come in a
thing called viagra viagra's are great
you know if you are having a hard time
getting a wet vagina you just take a
Viagra and you see and if you have a
hard time remember that remember viagra
vagina bladder I have a job I don't know
what matter if you can tigrin you're not
of the male persuasion um well my dog
almost died ah when Jim went crazy and
what do you have an exotic animal farm I
never know my giraffe you never know
when the human species are gonna run out
and you gotta create a new hybrid human
I don't think that works I know it's
hard to do but eventually you can do it
it's hard it's hard too much of the
confidence the courage I would love to
see your research but you know if you
can't get it up
viagra